그래서 제가 그런 거를 봤기 때문에
빌딩을 사러 오시는 분들한테 지금은
시기가 좀 아니신 거
[음악]
같다네 안녕하세요 빌사 남입니다
저희가 이번에 그 플래티넘에서 박진우
부사장님이 또 한국에 오셨어요
부사장님 간단하게 좀 자기소개
부탁드리겠습니다 뉴욕에서 따끈따끈하게
나아온 예 박 진우라이팅
시장을 궁금해하시는 분들이 좀 많이
계실 것 같아요 그래서 지금 현재
시장 상항이 좀 어떤지 설명해 주시면
좋을 것 같습니다 맨하튼에서 주거용과
상업 용을 같이 얘기를 좀 드려보면
주거용은 여전히 줄다리기를 하고
있고요 매수자와 매도자 사이에
줄다리기를 하고 있어서 가격이
오르지도 않고 더 이상 떨어지지도
않는요 상황으로 가고 있고요 상업용
부동산 같은 경우에는 이제 금년에
엄청나게 많은 물건들이 리파이낸싱을
해야 되는 시기가 왔어요 옥석을가
가려서 좋은 물건을 매 할 수 있는
시기라고 말씀을 드릴 수 있을 것
같아요 다시 대출을 해야 되니까
금리가 아마 되게 높을 거 같거든요
그리고 또 일부를 상환하라고 할 수도
있어서 리테일 시장이 너무 안
좋더라고요 그리고 요즘에 이제 오피스
시장도 되게 안 좋은 거 같아서
오피스는 좀 어때요 정확하게 드릴 수
있는 이야기가 있는데 어떤 분이 예를
들면 현재 밀리언 달러라는 돈을
가지고 있었어요
2017년도에 나트 미드타운에 밀리언
달러짜리 빌딩을 70밀리 주고
밀리언을 론을 받아서 샀어요 그
당시에는 공실률이 5% 정도였죠
임대료도 꽤 높은 편이었고 2023
4년 리파이낸스 해야 되는 시점에
공실률이 70% 올랐어요 임대료는
그때 수준에 70% 떨어졌고요 그래서
은행에서 어 건물주님이이 부분에
있어서 리파이낸스 하시려면 떨리
밀리언을 더 넣으셔야 됩니다 그래야지
어 저희가 리파이낸스 해 드릴 수
있습니다 빌딩 값어치는 떨어졌기
때문에 내가 100밀리언 있었는데
밀리언을 넣어서 떨리 밀리언은 내가
가지고 있는데 고민을 하시겠죠 내가
또리 밀을 넣어서이 빌딩을 조금 더
견뎌 볼까 아니면 지금이라도 조금
낮은 가격에 정리를 해서 어 좀
건져볼까 근데 건져볼까 하는 분들이
조금 더 많아지는 시장 싼 가격에 좀
이렇게 내놓는 그런 시장인 거죠
어떻게 보면 상업용 부동산 가격이 좀
많이 떨어져서 오는게 만일 거 같아서
오히려 좀 매입하기 좀 기회일까요
상업용도 주거용으로 가득차 있는
빌딩이 있고요 뭐 밑에는 상가 위에는
오피스 이런 이것도 상업용 부동산이
뉴욕에서 멀티 패밀리라고 오로시
레지던셜 유닛만 있고 임대용으로
가지고 있는 빌딩도 있겠죠 근데 저는
지금은 리테일이 오피스를 건드리는
것보다는 주거용 임대 유니로 채워져
있는 빌딩을 매입하는게 좀 좋을 것
같고요 상업 부동산 이야기를 할 때
이런 말씀을 꼭 드리는데 2016
17년도에 뉴욕에 오셔서 빌딩을
사시고 하셨던 분들한테 제가 드렸던
말씀이 있었어요 지금이 빌딩에서
1층에 어 예를 들면 3만 불의
임대료를 내고 있는데이 테넌트가
나가고 나서 3만 불을 받거나 아니면
3만 5천 불 더 올려서 받아야겠죠
근데 그런 시장이 없어졌어요 무슨
말이냐면 계약이 끝나고이 테넌트가
나가게 되면 더 이상 3만 불내는
테넌트를 못 찾고 2만 불을 요구를
해야 되는 시장이 된 거예요 그래서
제가 그런 거를 봤기 때문에 빌딩을
사러 오시는 분들한테 지금은 시기가
좀 아니신 거 같다 물론 그중에서도
옥석을 가릴 수는 있겠지만 일반적인
부분에서는 너무 지금 가격이 올라왔기
때문에 캡이 뭐 3% 3.5% 이랬기
때문에 그랬는데 지금은 오히려 10년
정도 지난 시점에서는 사실 수 있는
시장이다 말씀을 드릴 수가 있어요
코로나 이전에 빌딩 시장이 피크 때는
임대료를 더 높이거나 빌딩의 지출을
줄여서 빌딩의 어치를 높게 하는
방법이었는데 지금은 5% 이상 되는
물건을 좋은 지역에 있는 물건을
매입을 하셔서 지금의 피크에 있는
이자율이 떨어지는 걸 기다리면 이제는
캠이 낮아지아요 내가 이거 5.5%
혹은 5% 캡에 샀는데 4% 매각을
한다고 하면 그만큼의 차액이 작은
금액이 아니거든요 지금은 어 주거용도
사실 이자율이 떨어지기 시작하면서
저는 불이 좀 붙 들 거라고 생각을
하고요 상업용은 조금 더 매력이 있어
보입니다 제 생각이기도 하지만 저
역시 이제 많은 뭐 매체나 신문이나
여러 가지 잡지들을 통해서 맨하탄
안에서의 좀 공통적인 의견들이 이렇게
나오고 있는 거를 말씀드릴 수 있을
것 같아요 그냥 질문 중에 하난데
오피스가 너무 공실률이 심하니까
주거로 많이 바꾸더라 좀 그런 바람이
많이 불고 있나요 실제로 왜냐면 도시
입장에서는 비어 있는 B 클라스 C
클라스 오피스 빌딩을 그대로 두는게
도시 입장에서 견딜 만 할 거예요
빌딩이 비어 있게 되면 유동량이 줄고
그럼 도시가 한산해지는 오피스 빌딩이
주거로 바뀌면 도시는 조금 더 활력이
더 있을 것 같아요 오피스 빌딩이
주거로 전환되면 집값이 더 싸지지
않을까 좀 시장에 악영향을 미치지
않을까 생각하시는데 저는 그 반대라고
봐요 사람들이 더 많이 거주를 하게
되면 더 활력소가 더 있지 않을까
그렇게 생각이 들어요 그 마지막으로
탄 한 서울 크기 한 강남 서초구 합
면적에 70% 됩니다 59km 정도
되니까 인구는 160만 명으로
서초구와 강남구를 합친 인구의 한 두
배 정도 되고요 그 지역 내에서 좀
어디가 좀 핫한가요 어디 투자를 좀
많이 하는지 그런 것도 좀 궁금합니다
맨하탄 안에서도 힘이 점점
움직이거든요 근데 그 힘은 사실 좌이
보거든요 좋은 직장들이 어디에
오피스를 는지 거기가 이제 저는 로월
맨하튼이라고 봐요 허드슨
야드는 아직은 조금 시간이 좀 더
걸릴 거 같고요 허드슨야드 밑에 한
20 한 3가부산횟집
[음악]
그런 것들만 봐도 그 지역에 이제
최고의 직업들이 계속 생겨나고
있거든요 전통적인 어떤 그 레거시를
가지고 있는 지역은 저 아직도 센트럴
파크가 제일 좋다라고 생각이 들고요
저희가 관리하고 있는 300만 불
이상 되는 콘도나 뭐 400만 불
500만 불 되는 콘도들 임대료가
만불 이상 되잖아요 걱정들을 하세요
한국에서 투자하시는 분들이 이게
임대가 될까요 2만 불이면 한
2,600만 원인데 한 달에 이거를
누가 임대하여
아 잘 돼요 승인 절차를 밟으려면
그분들의 수입을 보잖아요 어마
하더라고요네 그게 뭐 그냥 소문에
의하면 거기서 연봉 1억이면 거의
최저 식은 받는 거라고 연봉 1억이면
맨하탄 안에 못 살아요 아 그렇구나
소독수 중도 우리나라를 생각하시면 안
된다 예 월세 주는 거에 대해서 어
그게 임대는 안 안 될 거
같은데요라고 생각하시면 저희가 다
자료들이
있으니까시면 또 보여 드릴 수도
있고요 좀 정리를 좀 해보자면 뉴욕
뭐 부동산 시장은 들어가 볼 만한
검토해 볼 만하고 뭐 주어 쪽이 되게
뭐 지금도 좋고 상업용은 사실
그전까지는 좀 들어가긴 쉽지 않았는데
근데 이제 최근에 좀 가격이 많이
조정되고 그고 괜찮은 매물들이 좀
많이 나오긴 해 가지고 좀 그런 것도
좀 접근해 보면 좋을 것 같다네
그래서 오늘 그 매네 them 부동산
관련해서 좀 얘기를 나눠봤습니다
나중에 이제 추후에 궁금하시거나
투어를 하고 싶다라고 하시
박진우 부장님한테 따로 연락 주시면
좋을 것 같고요 혹시 마지막으로 하신
말씀이 있으실까요 1년 안돼서
들어왔잖아요 네네 근데 더 자주 올
것 같습니다 자주 뵙겠습니다 어 일단
오늘 영상은 여기까지 하고요 어 다음
시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다니다
[음악]